[Musica]
io sono vitale e oggi nuovissima
challenge compro tutto quello che riesci
a sillabare diresti locale vuole fare lo
spelling famosissima in america che si
chiama bailey rae you can be challenge e
pensavo come cavolo si dice spero in
italiano e felice rilavare voi scrivete
nei commenti voi dite sillabare o fare
lo spelling la ruota una volta testa
dovremo girare la ruota è come potete
vedere nella ruota ci sono vari i numeri
di numerosi capita noi dovremo
utilizzare quel numero per prendere le
lettere e poi il comporre un qualcosa
che si può comprare el altra persona
dovrei dovrà comprare quel qualcosa
qualsiasi cosa
come scrive diamanti allora la lega per
diamanti plastica a quanto sopra i
15.000 piace faremo una seconda parte di
compete quello che dissi nella bara
versione solo cibo voto 5 la 35ma la
applichiamo di prevedere fase di impasse
carne nel cosmo prima vediamo chi inizia
primo round certa parigi razzo 533 cosa
voglio bere consigliere 3 in a tirare
sono indizi ha quindi tu devi prendere
due lettere e cercare di comporre
qualcosa da comprare e chi li scrive
[Musica]
il ph malissimo queste sale ora guarda
chi compra un aereo grande grande grande
io non ho bisogno di una vivere hanno
bisogno del mio piccolo anche un
aeroporto
ok ragazzi sono andata a prenderla stavo
pensando di fargli uno scherzo e fare un
aereo di carta e da lì l'aereo di carta
ma sono troppo buona stile che ho preso
davvero ho preso anche un aereo grande
vediamo come reagirà adesso eccovi
apportate l'aereo piero grande che ho
preso l'auto parcheggiata fuori anche
l'avere ovvero solo perché evitare ad
ora si muove quindi si muove ma non vola
ok vediamo se pol a questo aereo brasile
questa è una pista
a moroto la coda di mezzi erano disamina
le meno ma l'importante sono certo così
come con cestra si no non era già mio
per tenerlo
la germania ha mezzi a comparti primi
aerei agorà mori ora rinverdire
[Musica]
[Applauso]
come sospettavo berlino se lo vuole
mangiare un boccone per l'idea di wiki
come tutte le cose che vedrebbe arrivare
subito
io per 6 0
[Applauso]
bene quindi questo era il primo gioco è
andato bene è contento mi sono piaciuto
quello vero però bene a malaga contento
mi accontento gambe ma speriamo che
capiti qualcosa di costoso trofeo parco
sassoso così spazio picco e anche io ma
io non voglio un aereo cosa può esserci
con 5 al primo
dovremmo mettere un timer così diventa
ancora più difficile
insomma corpo allora facciamo che
contiamo fino a 30 34 o dare fino al 30
secondi nella torretta e devo riuscire a
trovare le 39 futuro e si sono lette
basket è piovuto e mette una parola la
parola che mi è venuta e bella gatta è
l'unica parola gheri e volete metterci
quelle tre carta ma non era una bella
cosa
la carta di credito la carta di identità
puoi essere la carta fedeltà la
cartuccia che comprino qualcosa che
prendi dal bagno la vado a comprare
lavoro comprovati a spingere carte
regalo perché ha regalato ben venga
qualcosa anche perché i miei quando
veneti nella carta igienica della scarsa
legato però se come la carta regala mai
cartone che lotito dal negozio ecco qui
ho comprato quello che voleva vita le
piacerà sorpresa la carta e campagnolo 6
pro starita compreso abitativi
importanti nomi della carta igienica
carta igienica rodio preso l'altro di
mangiare bene
ieri verde giustamente lo dovevo
prendere verde roma dei file e celeste
invece che verne no il verbo più bello c
recitava perché la posizione del verde
si dove statutario berlino
e io non sono stata fortunata come te tu
hai ricevuto un aereo io sono queste
carte scritto gatta e quindi carta non
mi veniva nient'altro in me
vediamo cosa ti beccherai o vai lì
accanto
giusto che chi è venuto qualcosa in me
lo sono ho preso un po caso di allora ci
siamo quasi è nato manca 36 gol devo
dire ho fatto un papa che cos'è guantoni
sempre i guantoni ai quatto ripert
ordinare nonno toni ma non per fare
pugile venire mi pare non si sa mai
magari mi devo difendere da qualcuno
andiamo a comprare questi quattro
mattoni ragazzi
eccoli qua ho preso i guantoni per
vitale in realtà moso se che stanno
perché l'ho presa al negozio di
giocattoli sono per bambini ma insomma
spero che i sì e no sono un po piccoli
prese guantoni
grazie prova li proviamo che c'è anche
marino potrebbe mettersi quanto in tutte
e quattro le zampe sicura di gara con
merlino senza essere morso così possiamo
giocare con gli stati uniti stanno
no no devono però non vedo wow sono
bellissimi tra l'altro adesso vede
aiutami a mettere un altro mattone
faccio le perline dei dati è impossibile
mettere i consolida solo di berlino
giochiamo bye bye bye berlino vuole
mangiare tutto ciò che a me ultimo mondo
quindi spero in qualcosa di decente non
carta 4
cosa c'è con 40 34
che cosa sono fatto cosa iniziamo alla c
con la c4 lettere e cosa dietro è che
cos'è cdb ottimo cibo anche perché
portare avanti tutto quindi
[Applauso]
filo no non vai a pregare il filo di
olio
l'olio una mera la mia la buona non mi è
piaciuta un bambino che cosa stai
facendo un po troppo 31 camere un cane
avvertivo bloccare con mese così felice
che ognuno produzione deve essere un
cane che si muove qualche annuncio per
l'incerto l'unione dei premi ok perché
io ho scelto quelli neri marcore stare
alle regole del gioco devi prenderti un
chiave che si muove allora facciamo una
sorpresa non puoi tu
agi cdv la cagnolina ragazzi eccoci qua
ho portato qui il cane per anita lei in
realtà si aspetta un cane vero però
quello che ho appreso non lo è non lo è
ma non è neanche un peluche perché
perché lei ha detto che si deve muovere
quindi è un cane che si muove eccolo qui
non vedo l'ora di vedere l'erezione di
anita a questo che mi onora e che si
muove anche i broccati che anita se
l'impronta
cercano così ieri equivoche d'olivo e si
è proprio questo questo non è un
cagnolino è un pupazzo ti avevo detto
non è pazzo
il gigante è tutto compreso il numero
che hanno detto che non andava bene non
è valido perché si deve muovere agosto
si muovono infatti come si muove non mi
sembra che si stia muovendo guarda dove
da un tale scritto questo punto
accarezzano sul dorso per ascoltare non
ci crede dai preso un cane elettronico e
subito possiamo produrre un altro cane
vero mi ama la musica tonino guzzo
benedetto qui
che cos'è il boca berlino che cosa hai
mangiato cotto ma tutto questo cosa si
farà davvero da fratellino e sorellina
se non solo mangiatrici malaparte chi si
muove mangia anche certo ci sono anche i
bocconcini di falchi la fiacchezza o no
questo non ho visto anna chip atom plico
la mia cagnetta è vero come reagirà
questo cane elettronico adesso proviamo
apri livello vedere vediamo come
reagisce
secondo me reagisce come tutte le nostre
cose guarda berlino e il tuo fratellino
o sorellina
[Musica]
non mi sembra molto contento che già
adesso si vuole con genere lo scatolo
forse non ha capito che c'è un cagnolino
elettronico di dentro corallino lavoro
eseguito farlo sia storica che li
aspetta aspetta berlino non puoi
lasciare così come reagirà berlino a
questo cane pinto elettronico già mi
sembra mi sembra molto interessato ma
non so se proverà a mangiarselo merlim
interessato tutto pronto a manzano
lasciate un mi piace se volete vedere la
reazione di berlino a questo cane magari
potremmo fare un video in cui
sostituisco berlino con questo cane
elettronico per 24 ore
lo vediamo come resi hills e berlino
quindi lasciate un bel mi piace nei
commenti se volete vedere il video del
genere così vediamo anche come funziona
questo coso elettronica comunque berline
sola volete a mangiarsi berlino ti sto
dicendo di no ma non è un bel mi piace
se volete vedere una seconda parte è
tutto questo me ne vado a
[Musica]
[Applauso]
sapere qual è il momento che abbiamo
piaciuto di più di questa challenger ora
vi lasciamo qua quattro cartellini e su
cui cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite
[Musica]